my producer is not here because he said
he couldn't come one fire him but you
know Pam I pay him a percentage didn't
show up not professional one fire um but
whoa because he helps me out he does
lots of stuff for me now does he travel
with me when I have to do the podcasts
on Mondays when I'm on the road no one
fire yeah by the way my producer is in
the other room taking a phone call for
something else he's here in another room
taking a phone call about something else
now one fire him but not gonna
ridiculous he [ __ ] makes a percentage
of what the [ __ ] I do he's in the other
room taking a phone call one fire I'm
not gonna cuz I'm good purse but come on
dude it's free country but do your job
show up dude my producers typing louder
than [ __ ] it's like he's got Hulk hands
one fire
technical difficulties technical [ __ ]
difficulties dude this [ __ ] thing's
falling but hey producer get over here
dude and you know what's coming one fire
room my producer just turned on his
phone one farmer by the way somebody
tweeted me [ __ ] a guy it was like Oh
finally found Chris's producer and they
any screenshot of it on Facebook and the
guy's name was Juan fire they're like fa
y ER or something one fire [ __ ] man on
fire
one fire one fire error right now use my
name congrats for this special offer for
week trial
hey what's what it's what he wrote right
now use my name Congrats
it's what my producer wrote one fire
that stamps.com click the microphone
enter congrats so you got to do is it is
um add my name Congrats Congrats D'Elia
it's free college you can post the
review on Yelp however if you do you
Nass Howell now my producer coughed in
the middle of me doing that one fire
cuz he could hear it in the background
but it's okay what's that mine hunting
show is [ __ ] good man it was really
interesting did you watch it one episode
he shakes his head he's like yeah it's
really good he watches one [ __ ]
goddamn episode see this is why one fire
so many fireable offenses one fire dude
one fire you know that's somebody's name
for real one fire
he gets emails that say hey Juan how
hilarious is that don't even put fire
you know how disrespectful that is hey
Juan when's the podcast up you know
disrespectful he's gotta name and now
every time I Drive by self-storage place
I sail it uh so what no public storage
is what it was public stores well one
fire immediately before can promote
himself to one hire you just [ __ ]
corrected me even though don't correct
me in public
seriously helped one hire one promote
hmm am i angry that this microphone
doesn't stay still and I have to twist
it myself one fire yes does it make
does it make me angry a little bit am I
gonna do anything about it no one fire
yeah my gun fire no one fire yeah one
fire every episode you know why cuz one
fire [ __ ] up dude
he's human by the way it spelled one
fire like the like the [ __ ] name Juan
and then F Y re it is not spelled W a n
and some people write it that way and
then now that's very [ __ ] stupid and
now let me explain why because one is
not a name Oh a Chinese guy that's not
Chinese guy he's a Mexican guy one fire
is Mexican now even though he's not
Mexican he's white guy and even though
you don't know his true identity on fire
the producer in essence is a Mexican guy
I love how you guys don't know who one
fire is he's like master killer from the
wu-tang you know I mean my producer one
fire always Google's the wrong [ __ ] he
googles wu-tang mask boot a mask guy I
had to slam one fire do it I had to do
it I'm gonna read some tweets here we go
you got some one fire he does 100 what
higher dude look the [ __ ] microphone
is falling down on
uh-oh bonfire now here's well he'll be
like will you did it well don't make me
do it one fire one fire dude
and one fire continues to be one fire uh
by the way how do I turn these two
headphones up top left I got it yeah all
right cool
worked one fire one higher but one fire
kiss was too long the first I say anyway
one fire Google cryptic art of course a
bunch of cryptic art showed up now
that's very stupid and that's why these
names one fire okay type obviously
greaser cryptic art on fire even deeper
this episode is the first episode we've
done in studio without the the
illustrious one fire so if this one goes
very well then
maybe one actually fire for some reason
my oh it's probably cuz my cellphone is
next to the thing
just [ __ ] interference cool one fire
myself in a tragic occurrence of events
on fire myself